[Music]
police body cam footage captures the
confusion officers faced in Las Vegas
trying to save lives in the face of
gunfire he spent nine to eleven minutes
raining down bullets on the crowd
[Applause]
Stephen paddock was meticulous fixing
cameras in his hotel to clarify there
were two cameras located in the hallway
so that the suspect could watch as law
enforcement or security approached his
room and there was another camera placed
inside the hotel room door people so
that he could see down the hallway on
the floor of the room one of the weapons
used to such deadly effect there were 12
bump fire stocks identified on the
firearms in the hotel room bunk fire
stocks while simulating automatic fire
do not actually alter the firearm to
fire automatically making them legal
under current federal law the Second
Amendment gun shop Nikko wants to buy an
ak-47 rifle one of the firearms paddock
owned a man who just killed Nico's
friend so your friend was killed and yet
just a couple of days later you're here
right
wanting to purchase a rifle correct does
that sit on easy yeah this is very
uneasy
I mean um as far as purchasing a rifle I
I have a few of them already
and you know it's just it's preparation
but whatever can't happen
less than 10 miles away his new frontier
armory where the Las Vegas gunman bought
some of his weapons the company just
told us that he bought several firearms
here earlier this year and passed all
the state and federal checks they added
that they weren't fully automatic
weapons when he purchased them and no
modifications were made here stories of
what medical staff had to deal with are
still emerging family members that and
you just try not to think about that at
the time your job is to stabilize and
get them what they need and then
crime-scene investigators are now
scouring the concert grounds still
scattered with personal belongings a
night of fun that became a fight to
survive
Ellen stai News Las Vegas Nevada